the next speaker is uh zeron wang
zaran is an assistant professor at the
northwestern university
and he is a jp morgan research fellow in
the reinforcement learning program
well thank you for that um so i will
talk about
a learning representation in rainforest
learning
so uh this is a new paper on eurips and
it is joint work with my student reform
she and also uh uh and also jorah who is
a research fellow here and also yongshin
at
georgia tech um so we have seen a lot of
the empirical success of green post
learning
especially deeper information learning
in practice so the key
is well so temporal difference algorithm
which does policy evaluation and also q
learning algorithm which does
essentially pulse optimization it turns
out to be very powerful when they're
combined with neural networks
so we have seen a lot of examples like
atari go and
robotics and autonomous driving so the
key success there is
a combination of the representation
learning ability of neural networks
which essentially maps the input which
could be a very complicated
object like an image to some latent
space which is much simpler
for like developing the policy
so it is combined with those
reinforcement algorithms
so the major theoretical challenge here
is that
well in the classical literature we know
that uh linearity is
is essentially incompatible uh with
reinforcement
especially for example in temporal
difference study so
i will talk about why in a moment but
this barrier essentially causes many
trouble
so if we have a non-linear function
approximately like a neural network
which is non-linear in the parameter so
we will have
non-convexity which makes it difficult
to obtain
the global optimal solution and more
importantly it could cause divergence
so the algorithm could uh you know just
diverge and
not converge at all so the question here
is that how
do we actually characterize the
evolution of the future mapping so
in the first literature we assume this
is fixed
so um in this in this work we show that
if we're using a two-layer neural
network and it is sufficiently over
parameterized we can not only obtain the
convergence but also
get a global optimal representation so
the tool
we use here is optimum transport which
is the also used in supervised learning
setting but
there are some differences uh next page
first
so the positive evaluation problem um is
that we want to
get the expected total reward starting
from a certain state in action
uh given this policy so uh the way we
we try to estimate this q pi is to
minimize the projected mean square
projected domain arrow
so t pi here is the belmont operator f
is the
function class we're interested in which
is the cost of two layer neural networks
which are over franchise
and d pi is a stationary distribution
induced by pi next page please
so the temporal difference learning
algorithm essentially looks like a
stochastic gradient descent algorithm
running on this
mean square bomb and arrow so because q
is a neural network there's none
complexity and also there's this bias of
semi gradients
so the together leads to a divergence
which is known
um like in the literature
next page
so in this paper we're considering a
two-layer neural network where alpha
actually controls the magnitude
and the number of neurons m would go to
infinity
and rho here is the distribution and
also it
it has a one-to-one corresponding
correspondence to the representation and
here we're considering over
prioritization where the width goes to
infinity and
we are trying to tune this our file
which we'll call over representation
uh to uh make sure it's convergence to
happen
so next page please so essentially we
show that
if we just using a mean field analysis
then we can establish the convergence of
q function and also
row which corresponds to representation
at a one over t where t is number of
iterations
here we're considering continuous time
that the t is the time
and uh also alpha appears in the arrow
boundary and
if alpha is large then uh this arrow
would quickly
go to zero so this is uh and uh this is
different from
the uh neural tangent kernel regime uh
where we can also characterize the
evolution of the feature
of the representation row uh whereas in
the mpk regime
the row is essentially fixed so the key
is just the
first variation of formula in the what's
a step space so that's the
i think that's everything